i
hola a todos
cantar
a ver yo cuando era pequeña era de esos
niños de esas niñas que siempre tenían
un montón de preguntas de que les
explicaba salgo y decía por qué por qué
porque siempre he tenido una mente muy
curiosa y esta mente curiosa me sigue
hasta hoy cuando yo era pequeña tenía
una subscripción mensual a una revista
que se llamaba ciencia y vida
descubrimiento y era para niños y te
hablaban de ciencia de tecnología de los
nuevos avances de qué está pasando en el
mundo y me fascinaba y la primera
pregunta que yo de verdad me quedé como
guapos como le vamos a hacer el tema que
más me sorprendió que es este tema el
tema de modificación genética donde
donde paramos o sea por ejemplo si
podemos eliminar ciertas enfermedades de
la población que padre no sea hagámoslo
pero
dejamos ese o sea en qué punto decimos
no para eso ya no o sea cuál es el
riesgo podríamos llegar a una población
solamente de personas muy altas con ojos
azules muy listas donde pones los
límites y eso fue el primer tipo de
pregunta que yo me hice y que dije quién
va a decidir esto y mi respuesta fue yo
no hay unos hombres blancos trajes
negros torres altas ahí ellos lo
conversan ellos deciden a mí ni me van a
avisar y un día me voy a despertar voy a
decir aunque raro la nueva generación
son de puros ojos azules y diré pues
decidieron que si valía la pena hacer
eso
pero a mí yo nunca dije que sería parte
de esa conversación pero por qué por qué
no podríamos ser parte de esa
conversación que está definiendo nuestro
futuro o sea claro que deberíamos estar
en esas conversaciones deben ser
conversaciones inclusivas que tienen
mujeres que tienen personas de todas
edades de todos los círculos
socioeconómicos no son estos estos
hombres que les puse en la foto que
deben definir únicamente nuestro futuro
entonces quiero que me acompañen les voy
a les voy a compartir las dudas que yo
me hago hoy en día y que digo y hay que
resolverlas y no no debo hacerme las
solo yo son preguntas que todos nos
deberíamos estar haciendo y estas
preguntas se encuentran a la
intersección de tecnología y ética cómo
vas a generar un impacto social con
dicha tecnología quiero enfocarme en el
tema de inteligencia artificial y como
sé que es un tema que los medios nos han
hecho pensar que la inteligencia
artificial es el fin del mundo
son robots que van a venir a destruir la
humanidad destruir el planeta nos vamos
a volver sus esclavos calma no es eso no
son tampoco que van a venir a robarnos
todos nuestros trabajos o sea los medios
les proporcionan entonces quiero hacer
un ejercicio con ustedes para que todos
aquí antes de entrar a las preguntas más
importantes diría de nuestra era quiero
que estemos en el mismo como en la misma
base que es inteligencia artificial
primero es todo tipo de inteligencia
artificial que vemos en las películas no
existe por ahora y según ciertos
científicos nunca podría existir lo que
existen ahora sus sistemas que son
buenos para una cosa no tienen
conciencia cuando digo son buenos para
una cosa a qué me refiero que el sistema
de inteligencia artificial que le ganó
el juego go al mejor jugador de golf del
mundo está buenísimo para jugar go
no puede corregir sus errores
gramaticales en la tarea pero no les va
a servir pueden hacer una y una sola
cosa muy bien ahora como ejercicio les
digo oigan me gusta mucho el actor
joaquin phoenix que película me
recomiendan
sí claro el guasón joker perfecto pero
en realidad mis gustos son mucho más
complejos que esto me gusta joaquin
phoenix pero me encantan las escenas de
make over me gustan las películas en
nueva york' los cachorros los momentos
que te dan sustos pero te hacen reír y
puede hacerles una lista infinita si
ahora les digo que película me
recomienda quien sabe ni yo sé es
imposible para mí saber eso es imposible
para cualquiera de nosotros capacita en
cómo utilizar esa cantidad de datos
procesarla y compararlo a la lista de
películas que conocemos nos quedamos
todos cortos
la inteligencia artificial ahí es donde
nos salva yo cuando veo un netflix jamás
le he dicho lo que me gusta ustedes
tampoco pero en de flix sabe porque
netflix va viendo las películas las
series que ves y va identificando
patrones y dice claudia vio la película
de joker varias veces le gusta joaquin
phoenix me lo va a seguir recomendando y
va a identificar cuales películas tienen
esas características para recomendarme
las íes igual en spotify es igual en
youtube entonces esas herramientas que
usamos eso es la inteligencia artificial
usar datos basados para hacer
predicciones futuras que avistó claudia
en el pasado que le gustará ver en el
futuro pues es como más sencillo de lo
que comparten los medios no entonces
quiero hablar de qué retos implica esto
estamos basando todos nuestros sistemas
en datos donde podrían haber problemas
les voy a dar ejemplos
todos conocen a amazon amazon quiso
facilitar su proceso de reclutamiento
dijeron estamos perdiendo mucho tiempo
mucho dinero en algo que podemos
automatizar y hacer de forma más
eficiente
hagámoslo agarraron todos los perfiles
de personas que trabajan en amazon y que
han trabajado en amazon dijeron hay
máquina ahí te va a toda la información
del tipo de perfil que queremos con esa
información identifica patrones le llega
a la máquina los currículums de gente
que aplica
y el sistema de diseño este no
corresponde este no corresponde este si
ya eficientiza muchísimo el trabajo que
vuelo no todas las empresas deberían
usar este tipo de sistema problema no es
tan sencillo tal vez hayan escuchado que
la inteligencia artificial es algo que
se puede comparar a un cuchillo que tú
la intención que le das es el resultado
que va a suceder quieres un resultado
positivo corta spam con tu cuchillo
quieres un resultado negativo a
puñaladas a alguien con tu cuchillo
error la inteligencia artificial es
mucho más compleja y al equipo de
programadores se les olvidó considerar
este elemento cuando estaban diseñando
el programa que pasó de repente dijeron
qué raro que no están llevando llegando
currículums de mujeres porque porque
claro amazon es una empresa tecnológica
entonces en toda la base de datos de
perfiles actuales y pasados había una
mayoría de hombres y el sistema lo
detectó y dijo ah no quieren hombres
entonces de las mujeres los rechazaba
imagínense y yo me pregunta ahí es pues
deberíamos tener sistemas que te ponen
como mínimos para asegurar que tu base
de datos es diversificada que es ética
que va a poner resultados positivos
otro caso dramático esta playera que
pasó
esta empresa dijo no yo super listo voy
a poner a correr un algoritmo en redes a
ver cuáles son los temas populares
automáticamente va a sacar las
tendencias me las va a poner en unas
playeras y paz a la venta en amazon que
listo
resulta que en breves hablamos mucho de
violencia de violaciones y esto quedó en
la playera y esta playera claro que
ahora la bajaron pero el hecho que
estuviera a la venta aunque sea por un
minuto
es inaceptable completamente inaceptable
yo digo ahí pues donde deberían estar
las colaboraciones entre humanos y
máquinas para que estas groserías no
sucedan donde entramos nosotros no
podemos automatizar todo no es tan
sencillo dónde está el límite cómo lo
podemos hacer
les hablé de los datos de empresas les
hablé de los datos de las redes sociales
de internet hablemos de nuestros datos
qué está pasando con nuestros datos
qué información estamos dando a cambio
de que todos se acuerdan del facebook
lens le ponías una foto de ti hace 10
años y una de ahora y enseñaba cómo te
habías vuelto mucho más bonita y más
cool y todo y a todos los encanto era
como si mira wow
pero pero en realidad qué tal que
estabas capacitando entrenando al
algoritmo de reconocimiento facial de
facebook para saber cómo envejece una
cara
qué tal no sabemos
pero hay artículos ahí afuera pueden
buscar el the wire que supone que si es
muy interesante los invito a leerlo por
otro lado otro ejemplo de cosas que
parecen que no tendrías problema con eso
pero hay otra historia atrás este yo
acaba de comprar una rumba ya ven la
rumba es esta aspiradora que va por tu
casa y mate a tu casa para no pegarse
contra las paredes o los muebles y yo en
mi casa me acaba de mudar mí no tenía
sofá idealmente digo qué raro que en
facebook me llegan un montón de
notificaciones de publicidad de compra
al sofá yo creo como saben que no tengo
sofá
hasta que la rumba no solo mapea tu casa
para
es información estos datos privados que
en ningún momento aceptaste compartir o
tal vez estaba como en letra chiquita en
la noticia de uso los está vendiendo
para poder hacer publicidad publicidad a
ti navia hacia ti y tal vez esté bien
tal vez es eficiente no yo buscaba un
sofá pero pero yo no supe que estaba
pasando tal vez yo no estoy de acuerdo
tal vez yo no quiero que se usen mis
datos para eso la cuestión es que yo
tenga el poder de decisión
en otro caso conocen este tipo de
dispositivos verdad los dispositivos de
asistentes personales me asustan me
asustan o sea qué horror y un día
hablaba con una amiga como sabes que
igual me tiño el pelo de rosa porque se
ve divertido dos segundos después en
facebook aquí tienes colorantes para
pelo rosa qué raro cómo supieron claro
estos dispositivos es o se escuchan lo
que dices esto suena como película de
ciencia ficción escuchar lo que dices
porque tal vez mediano solo solo me
escucha cuando yo digo hey civil pero
como se dio cuenta que tú dijiste géiser
y por qué te está grabando y está
analizando esa información y se
despierta cuando tú dices recibe y lo
detecta y esa información quién la tiene
esa información tú cuando hablas con tu
mamá cuando tus amigos en tu casa
conversaciones privadas están guardadas
en algún lado quién tiene acceso a esa
información
y me asusta yo estoy pensando en decirle
a mi me desactiva tus ir y yo no quiero
eso en mi casa
otro tema que de verdad y aquí digo tal
vez nos fuimos muy lejos el tema de
conocer la empresa gringa tony free en
mí
es una empresa gringa que ofrece un
servicio bastante cool es te sacan tu
mapeo genético y te pueden decir de
dónde vienes hoy eres 3% francesa 4%
canadiense 50% española que cool no osa
saber de dónde vienes es divertido pero
que estás dando a cambio de que cool yo
sé que soy mitad española que estás
dando estás dando tu información
genética que es tuya es única
cuánto vale esto esto realmente vale un
récord no para mí en mi percepción no
dónde y dónde va a parar esto o sea qué
pasa
esta información está regulada aquí en
la venden quién tiene acceso no sabemos
toda esta información la podemos sacar
de su uso de redes sociales combinadas
con la información genética que tampoco
está regulada qué pasa si cae en las
manos malas manos conoce en el caso de
varios casos de que está pasando en
china
en china están poniendo tiene nada más
del 10 por ciento de una población
musulmana minoritaria que se llaman
musulmanes we work en centros de
educación no son centros de educación
son campos de concentración es el
holocausto con el poder de la
inteligencia artificial el poder digital
en china tienen un sistema de puntaje
social uno de crédito social donde según
tu comportamiento en redes según con
quién hablas te dan puntos o te quitan
puntos y el gobierno decide que te da
puntos y que te quita puntos y claro
pues no es un objetivo eso y si no
tienes puntos que pasa tienes que ir a
los peores hospitales no puedes poner a
tus niños en las mejores escuelas no
puedes viajar no puedes salir del país y
te quitan juntos por lo que ellos
deciden que es malo
esto igual me dicen es en china siempre
no se siempre tienen historias raras en
china pero más pero mañana es aquí
no tenemos regulación tal vez hay que
tener tal vez no es una pregunta que yo
me hago pero como podemos tener
herramientas que protejan nuestros datos
y nos protejan a nosotros
ahora
de hecho regresando al tema de twenty
three en mí quien tiene acceso a esa
información
qué pasa si una fuga de información ok
que pasa hasta ahora han habido fugas de
información digital de tu clave
tú te metes a la compu la cambias ya
estás como protegido hasta el segundo
hackeo esta mañana hubo una fuga de
datos biométricos no es que mañana
cambias tu adn reconocimiento facial no
es que cada hackeo te vas a ir a hacer
una cirugía para hacer para que no te
reconozcan más claro que no qué
significa esto y cómo sucede como cómo
puede haber logrado a pasar o sea
sabemos que es un riesgo pasó de hacer
no sabemos porque no estamos teniendo
estas conversaciones porque nadie está
decidiendo
ahora tal vez me digan no por
inteligencia artificial
me asustas te un buen yo no le voy a
tocar esa cosa no le voy a mover gracias
para mí no es pero no es así es como
decir voy a dejar de usar facebook
puedes pero es una parte integral de
nuestras vidas y estas tecnologías
también si yo siempre hablo con cil y
bueno tal vez soy yo que soy rara pero
siempre estoy hablando con siri eso ya
es una parte de mi vida y pues echa a
penn en que lo queramos o no entonces
vemos el lado positivo porque no sólo
estamos perdiendo cosas también estamos
ganando muchas cosas y la idea es
asegurar los que podamos aprovechar los
beneficios que trae esta revolución
tecnológica mitigando los riesgos que
son considerables cuenta y fríen y
además de ser una empresa que me asusta
también es una empresa que ha
contribuido muchísimo al conocimiento
médico tener una base de datos del adn
de toda una población de la población
mundial porque lo puedes hacer desde
cualquier lado
permite analizar esa información y por
ejemplo han encontrado cuáles son los
marcadores genéticos que te pueden
predecir que tendrás un embarazo bueno
todo se volviera esta palabra que va a
ser tu niño antes de que debería nacer
nacimiento prematuro qué bueno poder
saber eso qué bueno saber que si se
puede predecir
que más nosotros bueno yo estoy
involucrada en un proyecto con mi
organización que ahorita les voy a
platicar donde estamos explorando cómo
se puede mejorar la educación en méxico
con inteligencia artificial cómo podemos
hacer que méxico ya no sea de los
últimos países de la ocde en temas de
educación que significa explorar eso en
el camino nos encontramos con retos
estos retos deberíamos o sea con esos
retos seguimos con el proyecto le damos
la vuelta lo dejamos ahí como lo
solucionamos para contestar estas
preguntas también hay que explorar y ver
qué significa y qué propones para
resolverlo otro caso que se nace
increíble la esquizofrenia es un tema
que los médicos no entienden es algo que
no entendemos porque nos pasa no sabemos
qué pasa en la cabeza de las personas no
se puede predecir es un misterio la
verdad resulta que con una de las
categorías más avanzadas de inteligencia
artificial que se llaman durón networks
redes neurales
puedes de alguna manera predecir la
esquizofrenia
si le preguntas a la red o sea si buscas
entender cómo llegó a esta conclusión
imposible eso es el reto de caja negra
en la inteligencia artificial que el
proceso es tan avanzado que ya no lo
podemos entender
pero que padre si poder predecir una
enfermedad que no entendemos qué valor
es un valor enorme
para la humanidad
pero por otro lado no poder explicarlo
los molestos porque si tú vienes al
banco y pides un crédito que es
importante para ti te dicen no dices
porque te dicen la máquina dijo está
bien no saber por qué no saber qué
puedes hacer para remediar la decisión
donde ponemos los límites es caso por
caso como podríamos establecer algún
lineamiento o una regulación queremos
tomar decisiones que no entendemos hacia
ese futuro queremos ir
y esto me refiero cuando digo quién está
diseñando tu futuro tu futuro y el mío
nuestro futuro
ahorita se ve así no sabemos a dónde
vamos no entendemos no estamos creando
no estamos teniendo las conversaciones
que puedan definir cómo nos sentimos en
cuanto a estas tecnologías que pueden
tomar decidió decisiones que no
entendemos hacia dónde vamos quién está
definiendo este futuro estás involucrado
en estas conversaciones y estas
conversaciones no son sólo resulta para
estos hombres blancos en torres altas
para todos
william se acuerdan el artista de black
eyed peas está detrás del movimiento de
deiro rights and human rigths si vivimos
en un mundo digital ya ya nuestra vida
ya no puedes hacer la diferencia entre
vida digital y vida física entonces
porque sólo tendrías derechos en tu vida
física esos derechos deben traducirse al
mundo digital
y quien más debería estar en las
conversaciones ustedes ustedes el futuro
de mexico como se va a ver qué derechos
vamos a tener donde van a estar los
límites las responsabilidades y bueno la
niña curiosa que les comenté al
principio de la plática ahora estoy
trabajando con dos mujeres increíbles
que van cristina y constanza y
trabajamos encima es una organización
basada en la ciudad de méxico en donde
pensamos en estas preguntas y decimos
que qué significan estas preguntas para
méxico cómo las podemos resolver estas
conversaciones son para todos porque
definen nuestro futuro de una manera que
hasta ahora una herramienta ha cambiado
nuestras vidas tanto los invito a ser
parte de estas conversaciones es urgente
tenerlas definir que va a significar
porque si nosotros no lo decidimos lo
van a decidir las grandes empresas y no
quiero de ver a bolt izar los estas
empresas pues siguen trabajando siguen
avanzando y piden regulación pero a
quién le toca hacer esa regulación
tiene componentes éticos importantísimos
con tener repercusiones enormes para
todo el país para todo el mundo el país
debe estar en esa conversación entonces
espero que no los hace usted mucho pero
suficiente como para pensar en este tema
y darse cuenta que nos toca a todos
definirlo y más allá de asustarlos con
facebook y decir cierre en la plataforma
no claro es darse cuenta que realmente
estamos dando a cambio de facebook no es
una plataforma gratuita y como la
podemos usar en nuestra ventaja
compartiendo este tipo de información
para que todo méxico sea parte de la
conversación y creamos el futuro que
nosotros creamos el futuro en el que
nosotros queremos vivir gracias
[Aplausos]